[Music]
i get sent a lot of requests to talk
about my weekly workout routine and it's
kind of hard to just explain
so i figured i would show you so come
work out with me
[Music]
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor seed so i talk about the
importance of gut health all the time
and a lot of people ask me my opinion on
pre and probiotics so probiotics are the
good gut bacteria and prebiotics are the
food that feed the bacteria both are
important for a healthy gut microbiome
so i like seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
because you get both a pre and a
probiotic in one capsule together with
24 clinically and scientifically studied
strains the way they've engineered their
two in one capsule ensures 100 delivery
of the probiotic to your colon so you'll
really reap all the benefits most
probiotics end up dying in your stomach
acid so if you've ever taken a probiotic
before and felt no difference it's
likely because it just wasn't surviving
the harsh environments of our gi tract
so seed is different in this regard so
we've got evidence that a healthy gut
with an optimal balance of good bacteria
can help to support digestive issues and
promote overall systemic health like
eased bloating gut immune function heart
health skin health and so much more i
also really like that they are
sustainably delivered every month
because you get a refillable glass jar
with your first purchase and the monthly
refills are delivered in compostable
biodegradable and recyclable packaging
so if you want to check out seed for
yourself you can get 15 off of your
first month's supply of seeds ds-01
daily symbiotic by clicking the link in
the description box and using my code
abby at checkout okay but before we get
into this a quick disclaimer that this
is not meant to be prescriptive or even
instructive i'm not a personal trainer
so this is definitely out of my scope
i'm just a regular person trying to
enjoy moving my body and like keep up
with my kids
so please speak to a health care
provider or a personal trainer about a
regimen that works for you so a little
story time here but before i became a
registered dietitian i was doing a
degree in kinesiology and while i was in
school i got my personal trainer
certificate because it was kind of the
thing to do in my program and this was
more than a decade ago so i am 100
not qualified to be a personal trainer
today i left that world for a reason it
just wasn't for me however fitness has
always been a really big part of my life
but i also try not to take it too
seriously so please do not come at me if
my form is
because let's be real i don't always do
what i know i should do
because i'm tired or it's hard or i just
don't want to so i've come up with a
general routine that keeps me active
healthy and mentally feeling well so let
me show you what my routine looks like
but first let's fuel up
so super simple this is one of my
favorite go-to pre-workout breakfasts uh
we've got
some
quick cooking oats
mama don't have time to cook the
steel cut oats from scratch every day
and
any kind of milk we have in the fridge
basically
i microwave my oats make it super simple
and fast
so it's a little thick
too thick for my liking but that's why
we add more milk
um next i'm going to add a scoop of
protein powder
and
a lot more milk
just to get it to the right consistency
[Music]
i don't like my oats super thick
very important always add
a little pinch of salt
to your oats
and then i always like adding like a
super ripe banana or i mean this is a
pretty big one so
i'll just kind of mash it up in there to
add some natural sweetness plus some
really great energizing carbs
little chunkies in there
and why you show all 10 minutes
okay
now we top it off might as well add the
rest of this banana
let's not let that go to waste
some beaut
from the straws
a little
natural peanut butter
and
we top it off
with a little hemp heart love
[Music]
oh and before workout there's pretty
much
always
coffee
all right let's move on so once or twice
a week i train using an ems suit which
basically stimulates your muscles with
tiny electrodes to help enhance the
toning effects so we're putting this
suit on so it's electric muscle
stimulation stimulation training
and the suit is equipped with
electrodes that target
target about 300 muscle um on the body
and what the electrodes do is they send
pulses to uh to the muscles to contract
harder and longer so you get a much more
efficient
um and
effective workouts um because you are
getting a lot deeper into the muscle and
engaging a lot more muscle fiber
so she's going to basically do like a
traditional workout so nothing crazy
like squats
planks push-ups um we only use very
light weights if we do use weights um
because the suit really mimics uh the
load that you would get from from heavy
lifting or um or resistance training
that's it there's actually some research
on its benefits and i personally have
found it to be really helpful because
the workout is only 20 minutes long
which is key
because my time tends to be super
limited in the day it's a challenging
workout but i really love it and the
time just flies by because i'm actually
having fun then one or two other days in
the week i will do a 30 minute virtual
session with another trainer that i love
again i typically don't have a ton of
time in my day for anything extreme but
30 minutes is a really good resistance
training goal for me pre pandemic i used
to go to different fitness classes
several times a week to get in lots of
different variety but i now split my
sessions between my two trainers
approaches to try to mix things up and
yes i do know that i'm obviously
privileged to have these kinds of
opportunities now on days that i can't
make a training session for whatever
reason because that happens my schedule
tends to be very chaotic i will
sometimes like throw on a little workout
app or a youtube video for some quick
little sets i personally love sydney
cummings workouts the best and honestly
sometimes i can only fit in like 10
minutes here and 15 minutes there and
that's great too like it doesn't always
have to be a big workout all at once i
generally take at least two days off of
doing any resistance training at all but
i still do try to move my body when i
get the chance i admittedly don't run
because hashtag childbirth i literally
had prolapse and my diastasis recti
still has not made it very easy for me
to even like chase after my kid on a
bike but i do try to get some walking in
most days otherwise i just find myself
sitting down at my desk or in front of
the camera all day and it just doesn't
feel good to my body physical health
aside i really find walking to be very
helpful for my mental health and for my
digestion if i'm feeling bloated or
gassy or backed up i will go for a walk
if i'm feeling particularly anxious i go
for a walk if i'm having terrible
insomnia sometimes i get out of my bed
and i go for a quick little walk to
reset my brain i am naturally a very
busy body it's just what comes with my
personality so i've never been good at
sitting down and meditating but this
feels like a bit of a walking meditation
to me and i definitely find it's helpful
i also get about 30 minutes in daily
just walking my kid to and from school
every day and i try to take my zoom
calls walking outside or on the
treadmill if it's not a super nice day
my team has basically come to expect to
hear the treadmill buzz in the
background on most of our calls because
that might be the only chance that i get
to actually move that day but now let's
talk about my post-workout meal all
right so for a quick little post workout
i'm going to throw together what i have
already in the fridge and make a really
fast easy quesadilla and a little salad
combo on the side for my lunch i just
got some rotisserie chicken here
that'll do that'll do donkey
that'll do
two little tortillas a little chicken
action
some bell peppers here
[Music]
and
lots of cheese
you can squeeze a little baby
good night
good night
[Applause]
let's get grilled up nice and hot
oh she's falling apart oh god
[Music]
burning fingers
healthy cheese
do i know that iceberg lettuce has
barely any nutrients yes do i like it
anyway also yes
i like the crunch especially to
rehydrate after working out
come at me
i'm going to throw the rest of my
chicken down for a little extra protein
i've got some roasted carrots here that
i pre-made for the kiddos and i
chop up a cuke
why is there leaf in my cheese
gotta have salsa
[Music]
a little salsa in one corner
a little chunky guacamole in the other
corner
this is just some basic balsamic
vinaigrette that i batch make and my
kids have
sucked this and bit it till it doesn't
work anywhere
and i'll probably have it with like an
apple and maybe some leftover cookies on
the side as well so
i feel like i need a little something
sweet to end the meal so
my kids favorite
if i were training with a fitness goal
in mind i might be more specific about
macros and timing etc but i generally
eat like three meals plus one bedtime
snack a day so my post workout is
usually just whatever i want to eat that
day for lunch again if i had specific
fitness or aesthetic goals in mind my
macros might be different i might want
to have a little less fat around the
workout and even more carbs in that meal
but i try to just build generally
balanced hunger crushing combos with
fiber-rich carbs protein and fat
something that i know will satisfy me
until i can get to that next meal so
this chicken quesadilla and salad combo
is just one example of a really quick
easy option and i usually just go with
the flow and if i'm still peckish after
my main meal i'll add in some extra
snacks so the apple plus a few handfuls
of my kids cookies were a really good
satisfying way to end the meal with some
extra carbs also i had no idea those
cookies were gluten free they still
surprisingly taste really great to me so
that's my general fitness routine in a
nutshell and this is just what's
currently working for me maybe my goals
will change one day and my regimen will
follow suit but for now
my general fitness philosophy is to a
move my body in a way that feels good
and b
don't do anything that i don't love
that's it at this point in my life
working out is not about changing my
body in any way it's about feeling good
in the body that i have and it wasn't
always this way for me like so many of
you i went through a phase many years
ago when i was still somewhat entrenched
in diet culture as i was trying to get
ready for my wedding and what i learned
was that i had to give up
so much and put myself through so much
misery just to move the needle like a
teeny tiny bit and not surprisingly none
of that would have made any significant
improvements to my health so i'm just
really happy with my routine and when it
stops being enjoyable i'll switch it
back up and a story so on that note that
is all that i have for you guys today if
you like this kind of video please give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on what you'd like to see me do or
talk about next subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]